und wir gehen jetzt patricia wieder
dorthin wo die katastrophe so ganz
besonders unbarmherzig zugeschlagen hat
ja genau wir wollen nämlich nach schuld
schauen dort ist unser kollege dimitri
so will und es sieht jetzt hinter dir
gar nicht so dramatisch aus aber du
warst in schuld in diesem kleinen ort
der so sehr betroffen ist von dieser
katastrophe knapp 700 einwohner mehrere
häuser sind eingestürzt mehrere dutzend
menschen sind dort vermisst und du hast
dich in diesem ort umgesehen der so so
schwer zugänglich ist auch für die
helfer und du musst zur klärung immer
wieder aus dem ort raus auf einem berg
dann natürlich auch da ziemlich
empfangen zusammengebrochen also um mit
uns sprechen zu kommen können
schließlich es auf dem berg in der nähe
dieses dorfes was kannst du uns
berichten wie geht es den menschen dort
sind die helfer dort mittlerweile auch
ein paar schritte näher an die menschen
heran gekommen
schuld war noch bis gestern eine
idyllische ort ein ort wo viele wanderer
und radfahrer unterwegs waren ein ort in
der eifel in den bergen es war ein
schöner ort
und jetzt ist ein großer teil des ortes
wie vom erdboden verschluckt
da hängen wir sind wirklich
apokalyptische bilder die wir gesehen
haben da hängen autos in den bäumen und
da sind kühlschränke liegen auf der
straße kaputt oder kaputte bäume
wirklich die menschen verloren haben
innerhalb von wenigen minuten haben
alles verloren was sie hatten
weil es was sie gespart haben was ihr
ganzes leben sozusagen angehäuft haben
ist verschwunden innerhalb von wenigen
minuten innerhalb von wenigen sekunden
war alles weg
wer mit anwohnern gesprochen die uns
geschildert haben das im prinzip man
diese flut nicht hätte kommen können
sehen dass das alle überrascht hat dass
das ist sie war noch sie haben natürlich
gemerkt dass das wasser steigt in deraa
haben da noch in ihrem keller erst mal
versucht die sachen weg zu räumen weil
man dachte okay das wird erstmal unser
keller aber erkennbar treffen und dann
merken sie das wasser steht aber jetzt
inzwischen in ihren wohnzimmern und dass
das so schnell ist und das passiert
hatte gesagt innerhalb von wenigen
minuten das alles verschwunden war
plötzlich schwammen autos an ihnen
vorbei gastanks und wie gesagt innerhalb
von wenigen minuten verloren sie alles
was sie hatten
und natürlich klar da sind
unbeschreibliche szenen die man da
erlebt also sowas kannte ich eigentlich
bis dato immer aus dem fernsehen wenn
man irgendwelche kriegsbilder sieht und
das erleben wir jetzt hier nacht nach
dieser wirklich flutkatastrophe die wir
innerhalb von wenigen stunden
gestern und heute nacht sehr vieles
zerstört zerstört hat wir wissen
inzwischen dass allein in dieser
ortschaft fünf menschen verstorben sind
und dass dutzende vermisst werden also
es war die zahl erst mal von 70
vermissten inzwischen hat sich die zahl
reduziert weil viele haben sich gemeldet
haben
aber die suche nach vermissten und toten
geht weiter in ganz aktuelle nachrichten
von diehl demetri aus diesem ort aus
schuld das liegt in rheinland pfalz in
diesem landkreis ahrweiler eben der so
schwer betroffen ist und während wir
hier sprechen sehen wie
die bilder die du in den vergangenen
stunden dort gedreht hast in diesem
kleinen dorf also du bist runter in das
dorf dort wo aktuell leben ja kein strom
vorhanden ist wo das handynetz
zusammengebrochen ist und hast uns dann
wieder zurück auf dem berg gekämpft
diese bilder hier übertragen uns
mitgebracht aus dieser gemeinde ganz
wichtig wir haben vorhin als wir mit dem
heli drüber geflogen sind die ganzen
häuser dort in diesen wassermassen
gesehen kannst du im moment sagen nach
dem was du gesehen hast sind ganz viele
menschen im moment noch in diesen
häusern eingeschlossen oder wie ist die
lage aktuell dort aktuell sind die
wassermassen zurückgegangen
die menschen sind dabei natürlich zu
suchen was ihm noch übrig geblieben ist
also wir hatten jetzt zum beispiel mit
einer frau gesprochen die haben ja
gezeigt wirklich das wasser stand
komplett er sie ihr wohnzimmer war bis
zur decke voll mit dem wasser das ist
komplett ihr ganzes ganze möbel alles
alles was die hts das stört liegt im
schlamm und die sich stehen vor dem
nichts jetzt gerade und sind natürlich
klar da laufen jetzt ist gerade erst
jetzt die ganzen rettungs oder
hilfsmaßnahmen die da jetzt erfolgen
zum teil müssen die menschen die noch in
diesem dieser zerstörten ortschaft
wohnen also jetzt noch geblieben sind
den helfern noch selbst helfen wir haben
eine mein kollege hat mit einer frau
gesprochen die den die in den
feuerwehrleuten brötchen vorbeigebracht
hat diese schnell und noch irgendwie auf
dem grill machen konnte
das sind wie gesagt das ist doch alles
im anfangsstadium die hilfsmaßnahmen
laufen erst an und es wirklich das
bietet sich einfach an
ein bild der verwüstung dort noch also
wie gesagt die maßnahmen fangen erst an
zu wirken also beziehungsweise mal
werden ist durchgeführt wird die
mätresse erzählt menschen die innerhalb
von sekunden ihre existenz verloren
haben und jetzt aber für die helfer da
sind obwohl ihnen auch selbst sehr
geholfen werden musste berichtet von
menschen die die feuerwehrleute mit
broten versorgen dann wird diese dort
auch kraft haben und du hast uns auch
einige bilder mitgebracht aus schuld
hier sehen wir aufräumarbeiten bagger
die unterwegs sind und
wegschaufeln was weg zu schaufeln gilt
jetzt der häuser zerstört sind dass ich
wassermassen durch das ganze dorf
gekämpft haben und dort wirklich ein
ganzes bild der zerstörung jetzt
hinterlassen haben alleine und die sechs
häuser sind komplett eingestürzt wir
sehen hier aber in diesem aufnahmen auch
dass die zerstörung dort wirklich ein
unfassbares ausmaß angenommen hat
ja das alles ist wasser das ist die
ursache von wasser das dort in massen
eben durch diesen kleinen ort schuld
geflossen ist dort wo die a sich
normalerweise rund um dieses dort
schlängelt ganz friedlich wo touristen
hin fahren dort ihren sommerurlaub
verbringen mit ihren campingwagen mit
ihren wohnmobilen und genau diese hat
die ebenfalls erfasst wir haben heute
früh schon bilder gesehen wo eben diese
campingwagen ganz einfach mitgerissen
worden
von der flut der adi normalerweise dort
ja vielleicht zwei meter breit ist und
sich jetzt diesen ganzen ort dort
gegriffen hat das sind nochmal aufnahme
aus unserem bild live elik ob der heute
gestartet in nordrhein-westfalen einmal
rüber über die hochwasser die
flutgebiete bilder dort das zeigt eben
genau diesen ort schuld in
rheinland-pfalz der ja völlig verwüstet
zerstört ist in großen teilen in
trümmern liegt heute und wo die menschen
das beeindruckt mich am meisten patricia
jetzt schon wieder auf rheuma das muss
man sich einmal vorstellen in den
vergangenen stunden haben die erstmal
die heftigsten regenfälle ihres lebens
vermutlich hinnehmen müssen 150 bis 200
liter pro quadratmeter
das hat uns vorhin unser bild wetter
experte karsten brandt geschildert dann
regnet das bis in die nacht hinein dann
laufen dort die keller voll die oberen
etagen vollmann versucht sich in
sicherheit zu bringen
man ist seit mehr als einem tag
mittlerweile wach und jetzt packen die
menschen dort in diesem ort anfahren mit
baggern mit traktoren durch den ort und
beginnen direkt wieder aufzubauen den
schutz erst mal weg zu räumen dort von
den straßen herren das sind jetzt bilder
live aus unserem
helikopter und mal das gesamte ausmaß
dieser katastrophe irgendwie zu fassen
zu bekommen und wir sehen hier wie sich
das wasser seinen weg bahnt wir sind
derzeit in einem helikopter unser
reporter jörg rocket ist dort vor ort
löcke verteidiger der rest kannst du
derzeit wir haben immer wieder ich muss
entschuldigen schwierigkeiten mit der
verbindung mit versucht trotzdem merke
was kannst du derzeit aus diesem
helikopter dieser blick von oben auf das
gesamte ausmaß der katastrophe
beobachten
wir sehen die verbindung zu jörg steht
derzeit noch nicht so richtig aber wir
sehen die bilder jetzt aus dem
helikopter der zum zweiten mal heute an
diesen katastrophen tag gestartet ist
nrw und rheinland pfalz besonders
betroffen wir sehen wie sehr sich
einfluss hier sind friedlich vor sich
hin plätschert ausgebreitet hat wie
viele menschen dort betroffen sind diese
kleinen den gewürfelten häuser die
aussehen wie spielzeug häuser die
derzeit darum kämpfen überhaupt stehen
zu bleiben in die wassermassen sie haben
eine derartige kraft einen derartigen
druck wir sehen hier auch schon dort
oben im bild der die bilder der
zerstörung wie sehr stabil gebaute große
häuser
da zum spielzeug dieser wassermassen
dann auch werden und hier sieht man zum
beispiel auch dass mittlerweile
überhaupt kaum mehr grün zu sehen ist
und es sind nur noch häuser und
dazwischen diese ja braune brühe der
flüsse über die ufer getreten sind und
alle gemeinden kleinstädte und dörfer
die dort in den ufern stehen komplett
eingenommen haben und das ist ja schon
die situation jetzt etwas danach muss
man sagen unser kollege dimitri seibel
der gerade genau dort war in schulden
dem kleinen ort also hier sind wir wenn
ich es richtig sehe noch über bad
neuenahr aber der ganz in der nähe dort
in schuld war in diesem so schwer
betroffenen dorf eben das komplett
einmal überspült wurde und das in großen
teilen in trümmern liegt dimitri sagt
das wasser hat sich jetzt zurückgezogen
also das ist die lage in der sich das
wasser aktuell zurückgezogen hat jetzt
schwingt gerade noch mal die kamera das
müsste schuld seien das müsste dieser
bogen sein den dialog macht dabei jörg
kannst du uns hören aktuell im
helikopter und kannst du es einmal ganz
genau beschreiben unsere ortskenntnisse
hören an dieser stelle einmal auf wir
versuchen uns hier aus der luft zu
orientieren vielleicht kannst du das
direkt aus dem helikopter besser machen
ich hör mal ganz kurz rein ob du uns
inmitten des lärms des helikopters turn
kannst das bild bleibt gerade noch mal
stehen aber wir nehmen das genauso mit
wir bleiben auf diesen ganz beeindruckt
den bildern dort aus dieser region in
rheinland pfalz die ja einmal komplett
überspült worden ist in den vergangenen
stunden eine flutkatastrophe die binnen
stunden binnen weniger stunden uns
ereilt hat und wie geht es den menschen
wie geht es den menschen die gerade
jetzt dort in diesen gebieten sind
dimitri säule ist für uns unterwegs auch
in schuld in dieser 700 seelen gemeinde
die so hart von dieser katastrophe
betroffen ist und er hat dort vor ort
mit den menschen gesprochen hat uns eben
gerade berichtet die den helfern brote
und essen anbieten in der stunde in der
sie selbst am aller aller dringlichsten
jetzt hilfe benötigen sind gerade in der
ortschaft schultern gekommen hinter uns
sehen wir wirklich zunächst die ersten
ausmaß dessen was sich hier in am
gestrigen abend beziehungsweise in der
nacht passiert
es sind auch apokalyptische bilder wir
sind wir in den bäumen
haushaltsgegenstände die geheimen können
sie jetzt kurz schildern waren begann
diese katastrophe katastrophe begann so
circa 56 uhr waren sie zu dem zeitpunkt
ihr zuhause
was sie gesehen haben was passiert was
habe ich gesehen dass war fing an zu
regnen erst leicht und dann immer
schneller
nun also richtig heftig und dann
schüttet es plötzlich wie aus eimern
dann kam das wasser schon über den über
die straße und dann bin ich gleich in
den keller wollte die sachen hochstellen
da kann das schon aus dem kanal
hochgesprungen
dann war schon nichts mehr zu machen um
die nacht musste ich dann haut und
speicher verbringen wie schnell stieg
das wasser also wann war das wasser aus
dem kanal aus gesprächen wohnzimmer wo
er zuerst im keller
aber dann kam das wasser von der straße
zuerst ein wenig über die straße aber
dann sintflutartig das ging ratzfatz
sieht man ja und hier unten sehr schwach
aber wie lange haben sie in diesem haus
gewohnt 45 jahren ihr leben
ja also ich würde sagen es war schon ein
komisches gefühl man sah dann die dass
tanks darum schwimmen und anja hier an
der fahne aus vorbei der anderen seite
von haus aus mit nachbar und die waren
schon am tisch wenn das gas strömte
richtig raus konnte man hören
jetzt schaffe ich fühlt man sich
wie solche zahlen recht nicht gut
wo waren sie die ganze nacht auf dem
speicher ja denn was da stand ja dann
schon ruckzuck ein zwei meter hoch und
das sind ja schon mindestens drei meter
was zu sagen gestiegen ist
april den schon hilfe angeboten noch
nicht ich hoffe dass das irgendwie jetzt
morgen oder übermorgen passieren wird
bisher ist keine luft
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren